all right granted gift autism foundation
is holding their 11th annual charity
gala on october 6. earlier i stopped by
finley toyota who are sponsoring this
segment to learn more about the gala and
the foundation
[Music]
well here we are at findlay toyota with
john barr and john it's always great to
see you too you know there's two things
that i truly love about you is one is
you always take care of your customers
first-time buyers repeat buyers and the
second thing is you're always taking
care of las vegas you're always giving
back and i know you have something very
special coming up what is it we do
actually we're involved in the granada
gift
gala which is taking place at legion
stadium on october the 6th and rather
than me tell you about it jc corrine
have at it hey corinne it's great to see
you
tell us more about granty gift autism so
granted gift autism foundation our
mission is to help children young adults
and families master living with autism
and the way we do that is through the
ackermann center so they do diagnosis
treatment therapies and transition
planning to the next stage of our
clients lives now the big gala is
october 6. what can we expect we're
super excited for the gala findlay
toyota has been a fantastic sponsor of
ours not just for the gala but
throughout the year as well sandy finley
is on our board which we're very excited
about and she's a great supporter of
ours the gala is on october 6th on the
field it's our biggest fundraising event
of the year and it's our 11th gala so
we're going to have mark chinook be our
emcee for the night super excited about
that we'll have blue men group do a
disturbance throughout the night a
disturbance
all right
and we're going to have some live
auction items up there we're going to
have a backstreet boys meet and greet
whoa
a golden doodle puppy a jet suite
package with a trip to newport as well a
louis vuitton bag and some other items
that we'll keep a surprise for the night
of no it's a it's a legion stadium it's
on the field like the 50r line i was
kind of looking at the blueprints of the
setup someone's watching can they still
get a table can they still attend i
could still get a table but there's only
a few tables left so i would suggest as
soon as possible and they can do that on
our website which is
grantygift.com and what a great night if
you haven't been to a legion stadium
here to give me to a great cause you'll
be out in the stadium we've got food
we've got wine it's a whole night the
whole night we got some photo booth
activations our vip will be in the
sideline club to see the raider at
locker room and the press room so it's
going to be really cool so the goal is
october 6 to raise a lot of money
where's that money going to go all the
money raised that night stays here in
southern nevada and granted gift autism
foundation so it doesn't leave the town
which we're really proud about amazing
things you're doing corrine and john
before we let you go i have to know what
inspired you to get involved well the
thing about autism it affects so many
people in our community and we're about
community it's things really near and
dear to our heart and
for us being able to help improve the
lives for everybody involved and be
involved is something that gives us a
great sense of satisfaction we love the
community and we want to do the best for
the community that we can i love it
thank you john thank you again corinne
and we'll see everybody on october 6.
thank you to findlay toyota for
sponsoring this segment grant a gift
autism foundation ackerman center annual
gala it's happening october 6th go to
granitegift.com for details and you can
bid on silent auction items even if you
can't attend